and at that point I it was the first
time I realized that you could apply
this technology to the mainstream
financial sector and it would it took a
while for me to make that connection
because the I didn't understand that
that you could separate in quote-unquote
separate the blockchain from Bitcoin of
course you can't and we can probably
talk a little bit more about that later
I'm I'm one of many who made a detour
around enterprise blockchain and have
come back Jimi song just gave a great
interview a few weeks back to lorrison
about that about his trip through
through music visit this is really
important right so do you think that
it's almost a requirement in order to
start out get excited you find out the
technology and then you have to explore
all of the intellectually possible
scenarios and then you end up coming
back to what is in reality probably the
most likely application
well it's interesting that's what Jimmy
did and he's obviously a technologist so
we came at it from different
perspectives but both ended up in the
same place essentially concluding you
know the enterprise stuff is okay for
things probably outside of financial
services right supply chain is where
it's taking off do you really need a
blockchain for that
probably not but the truth is that it's
a marketing gig and it's causing some
very interesting things to happen in
supply chain there's a company in
Wyoming called beef chain that that that
is doing exactly that to track the
provenance of Wyoming beef it's solving
a problem that nobody knew how to solve
and now this technology has sort of
opened up the conversation so I don't
mean to impugn enterprise blockchain
across the board but but I do believe
and I did say in a Forbes column
recently a lot of enterprise blockchain
was essentially made obsolete by the ice
announcement because what ice did was
break the seal in embracing digitally
native assets and that's what Jimmy said
to to Laura was ultimately why he
concluded that it was very difficult to
apply blockchain not Bitcoin so to speak
to the enterprise world because you have
a lot of things like trade breaks and
reversals that the regulator's have to
be able to come in so effectively the
regulator's have to be a super node and
therefore you really aren't
decentralized therefore you're better
off working in
in a centralized database architecture
to paraphrase Jimmy's I hope I haven't
miss miss stated I came at it from a
different perspective which was I knew
that Wall Street wasn't going to accept
Bitcoin so I was more from a legal and
compliance perspective thinking all
right how do we actually figure out how
to go through that intermediate step of
the walled garden to use ondrea's phrase
where you you know the intranet first
before internet that's the way
enterprises think they don't take big
big leaps they do take more incremental
steps and nobody was interested in in
wholesale replacing their their IT
architecture in which they've invested
billions so I knew this was gonna be a
slow process but I was pleasantly
surprised by the ice announcement that
they are embracing natively digital
assets that is a big deal because that
means they just leapfrogged over that
whole tokenization blockchain not
Bitcoin philosophy and ice can do a lot
that's very positive with that I hope
they do